Jack Black returns his PO the world
smooth awesome martial arts practising
panda I'm John and this is 27 awesome
things you probably didn't know about
Kung Fu Panda 3 to play the awesome Kung
Fu Panda PO Jack Black said he channels
his younger self when he was just
starting out as an actor black taps into
his own boundless passion for rock and
roll and acting and uses that to guide
his performance as the Kung Fu loving
pose much of the look of Kung Fu Panda 3
is based on a trip the filmmakers took
to China for example a lot of the
architecture in the Panda village
references what they saw during the
visit to mount Chang Chun an important
spiritual center as well as a natural
home for pandas the filmmakers also
spent a couple of days observing pandas
at the chengdu panda base a research and
breeding center for giant pandas in
China director Jennifer yuh Nelson even
got to hold a very sleepy baby panda on
her lap the movies creative crew then
drew on their observations of how pandas
move and roll to bring their own
animated pandas to life to get the right
look for the movie scroll which tells
the backstory of boug Wang Kai the
filmmakers took cues from a real-life
scroll called along the river during the
Ching Ming first of all which is such an
important and famous work of art that
it's said to be China's Mona Lisa
DreamWorks in the Shanghai based sister
company oriental DreamWorks worked
together to create two versions of Kung
Fu Panda 3 with the same story and
characters but with the characters
animated so that they speak in sync with
either English or Mandarin more than 200
people worked on both versions of the
film at oriental DreamWorks and they
helped to add to the movies cultural
authenticity for example by advising on
new female panda maymays costume and
suggesting the inclusion of traditional
Chinese food in certain scenes Jackie
Chan who voices monkey in the English
language Kung Fu Panda movies also
provides the voice of pose biological
father Lee in the Mandarin version of
Kung Fu Panda 3 speaking of Jackie Chan
because voice actors for animated movies
typically record their pots separately
confit Panda star Jack Black still
hasn't met Jackie Chan despite this
being there
third Kung Fu Panda movie together Jack
Black actually did some kung-fu training
himself for the Kung Fu Panda movies and
when he's recording his lines for pose
action scenes he likes to do a little
kung fu in the sound booth to make it
sound more realistic before the Kung Fu
Panda animators made their first movie
together not only did they binge on a
ton of kung fu movies but they also took
a kung fu class with top wushu coach and
stunt coordinator Eric Chen in order to
give them an insight into how the
untrained PO would feel facing someone
accomplished in martial arts animator
and story artist rode off gana dong
who's worked on all three Kung Fu Panda
movies happens to have over 20 years
experience with martial arts so he
supervised the kung foo choreography on
all the films he also continued the
animation crew's martial arts training
with his own kung fu classes which
helped the animators break down how each
character would move for example how
they should position their feet or their
hips to create the sound of PO flying
and jumping the movie sound editors
lined up a load of microphones along one
of 20th Century Fox's sound stages and
then released a tort bungee cord which
gave them an incredible 5 second long
sound with an elastic and spongy quality
when it came to the spirit realm the
movie's sound editors used a variety of
Chinese musical instruments to generate
the range of sounds they wanted to pose
chi or energy force and the villainous
Kai's Chi but because many of the spirit
realm scenes are about inner stillness
they actually reduced the number of
sounds they used and concentrated on
just those sounds that they needed to
show the character's emotional state to
produce the sound of pandas bouncing and
rolling along the sound editors made
their own musical instrument called a
gut buckets which is essentially a large
tin wash basin which they turned upside
down and cut a hole in and then attached
a stick and thread for the movie's fight
scenes the sound editors took the
characteristic woosh sounds you hear in
classic kung fu movies and expanded on
them creating more than a thousand
wishes for Kung Fu Panda 3
the original idea for the movies Jade
warriors came from Pan's Labyrinth and
Hellboy director Guillermo del Toro
whose executive producer for Kung Fu
Panda 3 and the design of the master
porcupine Jade zombie goes all the way
back to the first Kung Fu Panda movie
when the franchise's character designer
Nico Marley did a sketch of a porcupine
doctor who is doing acupuncture using
his own quills as needles Angelina Jolie
is back as the voice of tigress and this
time she's joined by four of her
children packed Zahara Shiloh and Knox
who cameo as characters including the
panda triplets while Knox's post our
siblings have already appeared alongside
their parents and other movies Kung Fu
Panda 3 is actually Knox his first big
screen performance but the jolie-pitt
kids weren't the only ones getting in on
the Kung Fu Panda 3 act Jack Black's son
Sammy provided the voice of one of the
movies bunnies and Dustin Hoffman's
grandson Gus was super excited to voice
one of the Panda villager kids when he
visited his granddad during one of his
recording sessions for the film's Kate
Hudson had such fun playing the super
confident ribbon dancing Panda maymay
that she broke down laughing at the end
of a couple of takes that actually made
it into the final movie to cover the
sound of her laughter the filmmakers had
to layer the end of her lines with the
cheering voices of the crowd in fact
Kate Hudson felt a special connection to
the movie because her own family had a
funky artist who spent a lot of time at
their home and they also often did Tai
Chi exercises as a family Owens speaking
of Mei Mei she was originally going to
be played by pitch perfect star rebel
Wilson but Wilson had to drop out of the
movie when the production schedule was
extended Hannibal star Mads Mikkelsen
was also initially set to play the
movies villain but bowed out after which
the oscar-winning star of whiplash JK
Simmons joined the cast to play the
villainous kinds like many of the Kung
Fu Panda team editor Claire Knight has
worked on all three movies in the
franchise but for Claire it's been a
real family affair while making the
first movie she met and married her
husband actor wayne knight who voiced a
role in the film night
is probably best known as Newman in the
TV comedy Seinfeld Anna's Dennis Nedry
in Jurassic Park
and while making Kung Fu Panda 2 Claire
gave birth to her son Liam he provides
the voice of baby po in that movie and
Claire's husband and son of both back
voicing big fern homely and Leigh Leigh
for Kung Fu Panda 3 remember the first
Kung Fu Panda movie which opened with PO
imagining himself as a hero so deadly
that his enemies would go blind from
pure awesomeness well there's a cool
callbacks that opening sequence in Kung
Fu Panda 3 s climactic confrontation
while making the movie alessandro
carloni who co-directed Kung Fu Panda 3
with Jennifer yuh Nelson decided to take
a leaf out of Poe's book so when the
movies animators showed him something he
really liked instead of just okaying it
and moving on
he jumped around enthusiastically
embracing the kind of passion PO shows
in the films and what a director
alessandro carloni favorite scenes in
the movie takes place between Po and his
father Lee in the Hall of Heroes Lee
tries on a suit of armor and playfully
head boots PO in the side which reminded
carloni of a moment he shared with his
own father Carloni is really into
motorbikes and one day he and his dad
put on motorbike helmets and his dad
started playing around bumping into him
now who's your favorite villain in the
Kung Fu Panda movies and why and what
would you like to see happen in the next
comfy Panda movie let me know in the
comments below i've got loads more
things you didn't know video so if you
love to know all the secrets of how your
favorite movies are made do please
subscribe and check out some of my other
videos and if you love animation i've
got a cool playlist here with interviews
Easter eggs and lots more thanks for
watching and see you next time you be
gay a movie lovers